ça paraît tout bête mais à chaque fois
que je mets le tracteur en route chaque
fois que je prends d'énergie pour mettre
la pompe en route etc
je me dis ah à thé observer la nature au
fil des saisons la contempler et s'en
inspirer en france 10% des terres sont
pollués par des métaux lourds 60% frappé
d'érosion et 90 % ont une activité
biologique trop faible les sols sont
meurtris appauvri quand xavier mathias
installe au sol à chédigny il sent tout
de suite un potentiel mais la terre a
beaucoup souffert
quand on est arrivé ici donc c'est mhr
boyer et c'était un chardon
essentiellement je me suis interdit
plainte ou plein d'outils rotatif et
c'est à travailler avec des dents
uniquement limité les retournements de
sol on a toujours travaillé avec une
seule idée c'est que l'air puissent
pénétrer dans le sol
là clairement on a vu une fertilité une
vraie fertilité s'établir même si bien
sûr c'est pas les terres de bosses mais
malgré tout on a un seul maintenant
beaucoup plus fertiles au bout de quatre
ans ça s'est amélioré et après le truc
c'est pas le perdre
jean philippe baudoin zhi a toujours
parcouru le monde pour replanter des
arbres
un jour il décide de prendre racine en
soleil si on laissait faire la nature
il faudrait 30 ans pour refaire un sol
pour que le sol se refasse tout seul qui
ait des plantes pionnières qui se
réinstallent et ensuite qu'elles fassent
remonter des éléments minéraux du sol et
qu'elle fournisse ensuite de l'humus au
sol si on l'aide là on est dans une
situation où ce jardin à 8 ans et donc
en huit ans en ayant rajouté beaucoup de
matière organique on voit qu'on a
interdit une terre qui commence est
équilibré tous les dix ans l'équivalent
d'un département français disparaissent
sous le béton
face à la crise du pétrole au changement
climatique aux limites de la croissance
infinie des alternatives existent
on est sur terre pour vivre plus que ça
plus dans la qualité et dans que dans la
quantité de ce que l'on dépense alors il
ya cette nouvelle génération qui monte
et qui n'y croient pas à ce monde
industriel et la permaculture arrive
avec une boîte à outils qui donne de
l'espoir
les quatre premières années ce n'était
pas rentable
maintenant en termes économiques
classiques c'est toujours pas rentable
bien sûr ramener ont ramené à l'heure de
travail faut pas que je considère ça ici
comme un travail mais comme un mode de
vie parce que sinon c'est pas du tout
rentable
après qu'est ce que c'est qu'être riche
c'est pour moi est riche c'est simple
c'est gagner plus que ce qu'on dépense
donc tomber mais les voitures vieux
tracteurs etc
je suis riche si je veux faire comme les
collègues et avoir un beau tracteur ne
fait faire un emprunt
je suis pauvre c'est du bon sens un art
de vivre et de penser pour arriver à
l'autosuffisance la permaculture c'est
comme une philosophie qui s'appliquerait
à trois champs d'actions seloger se
sociabiliser et se nourrir on a deux
agricultures n'a l'agriculture
nourricière avec lecture commercial
l'agriculture nourricière produit des
calories ion le lopin avec la vente des
excédents ou la vente d'une culture
destinée destiné à acheter le faire un
grosso modo notre agriculture
commerciale bio conventionnelle ça ça ça
n'aurait avait rien elle va dans mieux
parce qu'ils consomment bien plus de
calories que ce qu'elle arrive à en
produire
le mot apparaît dans les années 70 après
le premier choc pétrolier parmi les
pères fondateurs il ya mollison et
holmgren mais aussi fut croqua
ce hameau qui est un peu restrictif un
père m'a permanente culture ça vienne
d'anglais permanente coacher c'est en
même temps la culture permanente dans la
nature il ya une permanence une
viabilité
la permaculture c'est l'interrelation de
tous ces systèmes mise en forme dans ce
qu'on appelle un design donc ce design
c'est l'écosystème
pour le résumer ce que c'est que le
design j'essaie de faire le jeûne mots
voilà quand vous réfléchissez à votre
implantation
vous allez là que vous avez dessiné
c'est derrière quel est mon dessin en
fait
ainsi xavier a conçu un projet avec
trois zones importantes
la première nécessite le plus
d'interventions la seconde est un verger
et la troisième lui sert à stocker le
bois de chauffage
les feuilles de salade sur les moeurs au
compost c'est pas mal et qui mentent
façon on va pas les mettre à la poubelle
donc c'est pas mal et si vous avez des
poules et vous donner les feuilles de
salade aux poules vous récupérer les
eaux et de la zot tout est logique en
fin de compte quand c'est conçu comme ça
donc ça c'est pas moi qui l'inventé on
est vraiment sur les bases de la
permaculture
mais il ya un côté cercle vertueux
rationnel on retombe toujours sur nos
pattes
bah oui par les cas récents devant la
maison c'est devant la maison comptons
cette idée de zone est de créer des
zones où veut effectivement les moutons
ils sont au bout on n'a pas besoin d'y
aller en permanence j'y vais tous les
jours
tous les jours je m'assurer que ça se
passe bien qu'ils aient pas de souci
donc c'est minimum une fois
néanmoins c'est pas le même nombre de
visites que pour que pour un petit carré
potager ou pour un futur potager entre
observe
c'est le travail de la nature c'est du
boulot en a on a préparé le sol
et puis on l'a surtout payet en a mis
beaucoup de matière végétale mais c'est
incroyable à partir du moment donné où
on laisse des arbres s'exprimer comment
la nature reprend reprend sa force il
faut juste l'aider un peu
aujourd'hui on en a plein de terrains
dégradés dont le pont donnant un petit
coup de main ça repartirait on est à la
lisière de ce que sera la leur la forêt
jardin quand ces arbres là mon avis ils
auront la taille des autres derrière
là il ya un kiwi il a vraiment souffert
là j'allais me un kiwi ben tu vois il a
le kiwi la cram et coiteux lui n'a pas
résisté à la sécheresse
alors est-ce qu'on peut passer ici tu
vois le terrain tels que bon là il ya
une belle angèle asperges
mais tu vois le terrain à côté qui
d'ailleurs a été passée au roundup juste
avec quelques quelques framboisiers et
là tu vois que le sol ici quand tu real
le seul ici ouais voilà c'est
pratiquement plus du sable
voilà limite la frontière entre les deux
pays et donc ça c'est en même temps ta
peau de protection se dire que l'aps à
la fois c'est un réservoir de
biodiversité pour tes oiseaux des
insectes et c est à la fois tu protèges
ton sol et en même temps tu te protège
du vent des coups de vent donc ta elle
est absolument essentiel comme peau
extérieure
c'est purement symbolique 1 mais j'adore
ça
donc c'est l'association des trois
plantes la courge apporte de la
fraîcheur et de l'ombre âge limite un
peu l'enherbement le maïs servent de
tuteurs et notre haricots qui est une
légumineuse qui fixent l'azoté
atmosphérique et le restitue au sol et
il fait qu'il n'y a pas d' épuisement en
azote du sol et on a une céréale une
légumineuse est un fruit des trois qui
se transporte et qui se stockent c'est
le cumul entre ces différentes plantes
entre les méthodes qu'on va appliquer
sur le sol qui font qu'on sait si on est
dans une bonne direction où il faut
revoir autrement après tant que ça
pousse sans intrants chimiques parce que
les intrants chimiques c'est de synthèse
c'est de la triche ça marche
voilà c'est un coup énorme 1 après un
pour l'environnement mais ça fonctionne
ça pour gagner c'est tout à fait
impressionnant
au sud d'orléans en hiver jérôme dauphin
recouvre son sol lui aussi à une
démarche permaculture elle mais ils
appliquent en ville voilà ici
quatre mois plus tard devant les mêmes
jouent un peu plus gros alors toutes les
épluchures que j'ai mis pendant au moins
deux mois toutes les semaines ce sont
des composés à la surface ça donne une
espèce de terreau alors là qui est très
sec et qui était partiellement incorporé
par des vers de terre et qui a profité
aux choux
alors ici il ya une association qui
marche assez bien entre des pommes de
terre et des pois et les pois ou
l'intérêt de d'empêcher les doryphores
de venir ils n'ont rien inventé ils
prennent soin de la terre de l'homme et
partagent toutes les ressources
équitablement faut pas oublier surtout
qu' il ya la zone 1 2 3 mais la ville la
plus importante la zone zéro c'est celle
de sa famille dire que tout ça ça n'a
pas de sens s'il n'y a pas une famille
qui peut sourire au milieu de tout ça
voilà la permaculture réinsère la vie en
groupe est un des précurseurs au
danemark en 68 et le cora ou zing et on
a calculé à cette époque qu'une famille
s'ils vivaient dans un coma ou zid on
dans un habitat partagé un seul des
membres devaient n'avait besoin d'aller
travailler en dehors que deux jours et
demi par semaine
la première diversification d'un
agriculteur c'est que sa femme ait
travaillé à l'extérieur voilà surtout
quand on a un côté un petit peu
particulier comment je voulais pas
d'emprunt pas de prime pas de subvention
à rien du tout donc à part qu'elle parce
que c'est ça aussi qui permet de
conserver une liberté vraiment total une
subvention ou une prime c'est un collier
et un colis c'est fait pour accrocher
une laisse vivre autrement
simplement en phase avec ce qui nous
entoure le sol l'arbre lots des éléments
qui se complètent
moi j'ai essayé d'organiser le cycle de
l'eau pour que essayé d'être un maximum
autonome on peut pas avoir une autonomie
complète mais il n'y a pas d'eau perdus
ici c'est que l'eau de lavage et cetera
l'eau de l'eau des bâtiments et que
c'est tout et collecter tous retournent
à la barre néanmoins on a quand même des
compléments qu'ils viennent d'une
fontaine vont prendre l'eau et là le lot
et trophies et elle est polluée
c'est comme ça un sou pour les plantes
et 2 pour la terre ici les plantes sont
rustiques
sauvage comme c'est formidable arbustes
avec un poivrier du sichuan
la récolte commence au bout de quatre
ans car rapide 1 quand même pour un
arbre au bout de six ans qui n'en avait
beaucoup trop ça veut dire qu'au bout de
six ans vous offrez c'est quand même
génial d'arriver chez des gens avec des
amis et c'est avec un sachet de poivre
du sichuan récoltés à la maison ça c'est
vraiment étonnant te dire qu'on peut
faire un poivre de très haute qualité
chacun dans son jardin et même sur une
terrasse ça c'est le laisser steria
formose à ce qu'on appelle l'arbre aux
faisans
il est magnifique il est vraiment
sublime c'est très beau très rustique ça
pousse très haut et ça va faire des
petites baies chaque petite baie
minuscule a un goût de caramel
invraisemblable une baie dans un yaourt
ou fait un yaourt au caramel
le problème de cette baissé que pour
qu'elle soit bonne il faut qu'elle soit
complètement mûr elle est
intransportable jamais vous ne pourrez
en acheter
alors là pour ce qu un jardin c'est
bingo parce que on peut avoir ce petit
plaisir unique on pourra jamais trouver
ça dans le commerce
tout est arrivé
avant d'être permaculture il faut être
jardinier l'école nationale de paysage
de versailles fait appel à l'expérience
de xavier mathias depuis quatre ans ici
chaque année ils forment une quinzaine
de stagiaires sous l'oeil bienveillant
de son créateur jean baptiste de la
quintinie une particularité ce plan créé
avec lie normalement plutôt sur but
en laissant affleurer lapointe celui là
au contraire on va chercher à le
descendre et il va s'enterrer au fil de
la saison
à chaque fois que j'arrive il n'y a pas
une fois où il n'y a pas un moment
enfin ça paraît un petit peu bête à dire
mais oui un moment d'émotion ça fait
quand même drôle de casse pas rien est
ce qui est génial c'est que on ait la
possibilité de faire ça ici qu'on nous
la laisse sans contrainte sans
restriction et c'est même avec des clous
mende et des jardiniers du potager du
roi pour des plantes
on est dans les changes moi ce qui
m'épate cclat ils sont pas encore à
maturité ils sont pas encore goûté et tu
vois la profondeur de seul qu'on a ici
pour lui le changement viendra de la
ville les citadins paraissent utopique
mais au moins ils essaient va pas
forcément être à sa place après mais dès
que dès qu'elle entre en dormance tu
sors le pied puis voilà atteint jusque
là bien jolie qui vont quand même un
deviendra permaculture qui veulent
devenir moi mon gamin je lui fais semer
des radis
alors ça commence par là par les gestes
de base du jardinier
et puis après chaque individu va
développer son expérience son ressenti
par rapport au sol par rapport aux
plantes par rapport à ce qu il veut
aussi parce que faire pousser des
rallyes ça peut paraître anodin mais on
peut les aimer piquant ou pas du tout
piquant les radis ont il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui les gens dans le commerce
ils veulent des radicaux
c'est peut-être ridicule depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale la semence est
devenu un moyen lucratif elle a été
accaparé par des multinationales qui l'a
modifié génétiquement pour la rendre
plus rentable et en être les seuls
dépositaires de toute façon les graines
circulent les graines s'échangent et
puis on a aussi des très très bon
semenciers en france je leur tire mon
chapeau vraiment pour les jardiniers
amateurs qui veulent trouver des belles
variétés variété fixe reproductible à
l'identique traditionnelle et s'est
adaptée vraiment à des sols adapté à des
climats voilà il ya plein de très bons
ce dossier il ya plus à faire bien
germyn ans et c'est effectivement dans
la grande distribution les verra pas
mais mais il ya plein de raisons
maintenant sur internet qui permettent
d'y accéder très facilement même par
catalogue papier
xavier ne cultive pas sans ou contre
mais avec son environnement il bichonne
sa terre et ses plantes c'est un
passionné mais il reste réaliste
tous les stages en permaculture qui a
moi j'aimerais que ce soir une pour une
permaculture jardinières ehpad
maraîchère professionnels moi j'ai pas
envie de voir ces gamins a tapé dans le
mur parce que effectivement c'est pas
c'est pas réaliste c'est pas applicable
à tous
quand ils arrivent ici je reprends
toujours un
ce message de fut qu au kaki pour matin
vraiment un des pères de la permaculture
fut coca et l'écrit dans la révolution
d'un brin de paille c'est écrit que lui
ce qu'il aime pas c'est que les
étudiants qui monte à son verviers
viennent pour faire comme lui et
peut-être qu'il en est dans une vision
un peu bouddhiste mais peut-être que
finalement c'est pas tellement le
résultat qui compte
mais que le chemin le chemin qu'on va
suivre est important